how worried should we be about
artificial sweeteners
you know I don't know uh would be the
short answer I I think that this is
another one of those things where uh boy
people really love to demonize these
things
um but if you if you really just want to
look at the facts let's talk about facts
right so aspartame which is the original
kind of the OG sweetener uh everybody
loves to demonize aspartame or
NutraSweet but the reality of it is if
there is toxicity to it
probably impossible to measure at
regular doses this is a substance that
at least the last time I checked had
more data on it from a safety
perspective than any other molecule
tested by the FDA you're kidding no it's
it's just because again it's been around
since the 1960s right so
does that mean that if you
consume the equivalent of 12 cans of
diet soda a day it's safe probably not
but we don't know right so
um where do I think these sweeteners
potentially reek the most Havoc
you know one is I I think that they
probably increase your appetite for
sugar anyway so if you're if you're
consuming them in an effort to avoid
sugar
um you have to be just mindful of the
fact that am I robbing Peter to pay Paul
um if you really want to eliminate sugar
as one of your dietary strategies uh you
might just be better off reducing sweet
things altogether and what you'll
discover because I've gone I've done
this myself I've had periods in my life
where I've been you know very dogmatic
about restricting sugar I'm not that
dogmatic about it these days right but
when I have been you know one of the
things I noticed was how unbelievably
sweet things are that I used to not
think were that sweet like berries you
know like you know raspberries aren't
generally thought of as the sweetest
thing in the world but when you
completely eliminate artificial
sweeteners and regular sweeteners you
know after a few months berries become
insanely sweet you know 85 chocolate
becomes mind-bogglingly sweet as opposed
to what most people would think but it's
kind of bitter
um you know there was a recent study
published that looked at uh one
particular sweetener erythritol and
um it was a pretty poorly done study
um but look it asked some interesting
questions right which is you know is a
metabolite of this potentially
atherogenic I was androgenic uh would it
lead to or cause atherosclerosis what's
that cardiovascular disease sort of the
the the inflammatory disease of the
coronary arteries and other arteries
um
again I I think the data are are pretty
underwhelming that artificial sweeteners
are harmful but I also think there's
probably a class of differences between
them so my personal favorite of all of
them is something called allulose
um allulose is it's basically natural it
is an enantomer of fructose meaning it's
a molecule that's almost identical to
fructose with one very minor structural
change
what's unique about it is it has in my
opinion the best taste because the thing
I don't like about artificial sweeteners
is I just don't like the taste I
actually like the taste of sugar I don't
like the taste of you know saccharin I
don't really like the taste of aspartame
I certainly don't like the taste of
stevia I mean that to me makes me want
to vomit but alulose has the same taste
the same mouth feel as sugar and the
only drawback is it's only 70 is sweet
which is not a real drawback because you
could always dose it up if you want it
also has the added benefit of it appears
to actually reduce blood glucose a
little bit it appears to have an effect
where it pulls glucose
um into the kidney and like basically
increases the filtration glomerular
filtration of glucose so it slightly
lowers glucose not as potently as
something called a an sglt2 inhibitor
which is a class of drug that does that
but it's it's very interesting
nonetheless so
um you know I guess if I were thinking
about how I would consume it I would
probably consume more allulose than
other things but unfortunately it's
still not that prevalent in Foods you
have to you have to just buy the
allulose itself so if I'm making
something I'll use allulose in it what I
like about this framing is it gets to
one of the reasons why doing a
randomized control trial for diet stuff
is so hard because how are you going to
be able to control for the psychological
training that having a sweet thing even
if it is a zero calorie sweetening even
if it's a zero calorie sweet thing with
no Downstream risks to your body unless
you take it at insane dosages
how are you going to be able to control
for what that does psychologically to
people's expectations of the sweetness
of their foods of the frequency of
having sweet things throughout their
diet
um yeah I think that's a really nice
little microcosm there one of the thing
I'm wearing a wood band at the moment
um some people are drowning in data now
right we've gone from a world where we
knew nothing to where some people know a
lot but I would guess on average that
even people who care about the health
and fitness are still mostly not wearing
a Tracker they're still mostly not
getting blood panels done they're still
mostly not going and getting a full body
MRI scan etc etc
what are the most important metrics for
someone who is completely uh
unindoctrinated into the world of
looking at Vital Signs within their body
what are the most important metrics for
people to be looking at
well I mean again I I have a pretty long
list on that because we're we're holding
ourselves to a pretty high bar so the
way I think about this is what are the
inputs to what what I call the longevity
risk assessment
so
um there were basically about seven or
eight things that are a threat to your
length of life and quality of life we've
talked about them already right so
cardiovascular disease cerebrovascular
disease cancer neurodegenerative disease
Orthopedic injury emotional distress
misery like all those things right
so how do we know how you're stacking up
on all of those things what are the
inputs to do them so yeah blood tests
family history selective genetic testing
colonoscopy MRI liquid biopsy VO2 max
Test Zone 2 test dexa scan I mean the
list is long and I I think in our Matrix
we have over 40 things that go into that
or over 40 inputs that go into our risk
assessment and then that risk assessment
leads to outputs so what do you do in
response to the the ranking of risk
based on those things okay run the
Matrix go and do those things and then
let's come back and measure and do again
so it's hard for me to say what the most
important is because it really comes
down to an individual so if an
individual shows up and they have a
significant family history of
cardiovascular disease well look a CT
angiogram is going to be very important
and a blood test that's measuring LP
little a lipids and APO B is essential
because you have to know which you know
which of these things is responsible for
that you know certainly you know a
continuous blood pressure monitor or at
the at a minimum you know we would have
patients checking their blood pressure
at home two to three times a day for a
month again super low Tech right you
might think how is that interesting well
it's enormously interesting because
blood pressure
is one of the biggest risk factors for
Alzheimer's disease and cardiovascular
disease so again people are obsessed
with things like you know their sleep
data but don't forget the really you
know you know less sexy stuff that we
could have measured forever such as
blood pressure but knowing how to
measure blood pressure accurately is
important and I I think you know
undiagnosed hypertension is an epidemic
in this country what do people get wrong
when measuring blood pressure the first
thing they get wrong is they don't
measure it but assuming they do measure
it
um they're not stationary for five
minutes before they measure it they
don't have the cuff on correctly they
don't have their arm in the right
position you know if your arm is too low
or too high you're going to get an
inaccurate reading your arm really needs
to be the cuff needs to be right at the
level of your heart
um you you have to pay very close
attention to where the cuff tells you to
put it you know you want to be about an
inch above the break in your arm and
there's a a good cuff will tell you
where the how to line it up with the
brachial artery in your arm
you don't want to have just had coffee
right before you do it you don't want to
be sitting like I am with your legs
crossed your legs need to be uncrossed
so there's a whole protocol for how to
do this and there's a very good study
called the Sprint study that that really
established the the measurement standard
for how to establish
um a proper measurement for blood
reading which was you know five minutes
sitting stationary without doing
anything stimulating measurement five
minutes of you know doing nothing again
repeat measurement five minutes repeat
measurement so 15 minutes to get three
measurements taking the average that's a
blood pressure now we don't ask our
patients to do that we ask them to do it
once but two to three times a day so you
should even out any inconsistencies yeah
and you'll also notice trends like are
you normal in the mornings but elevated
in the afternoons and uh you know the
data are really clear that anything
above 120 over 80 has long-term risk
associated with it and so when we see
people that have an elevated blood
pressure we want to make sure we're
addressing that and there's lots of ways
to address it before you have to go down
the pharmacologic pack but if you have
to go down that path you're much better
off going down to protect your kidneys
your brain and your heart what
is good and what is bad about different
types of cuffs or automatic cuffs okay
yeah so the gold standard is of course a
manual cuff so having an actual person
yeah who's who's got a stethoscope on
the brachial artery and measuring your
blood pressure the problem is unless
you're you know you have like for me
that's what I do typically because my
wife can measure my blood pressure even
I can measure my own blood pressure so
marry someone who is trained for taking
blood pressure that's what you're saying
but the automated cuffs are pretty good
um in me they run high so across the
board automatic automated cuffs tend to
run 10 to 15 millimeters per Mercury
high systolically and they're accurate
diastolically that's just a glitch I
have never been able to come up with a
compelling explanation for why but I'm
not unique in this
um I we do see this uh in a number of
people where the the gold standard runs
lower than the than the cuff
um
so the challenge of doing an a manual
cuff when you're at your doctor's office
is the challenge of having your blood
pressure checked at the doctor's office
for some people it produces this
syndrome called white coat hypertension
where my mom's got that yeah they just
you you sort of get you know and by the
way the other thing is most the time you
walk into the doctor's office they don't
even adhere to this principle right five
minutes yeah yeah you sort of run in
from the parking lot run up the flight
of stairs sit down in the waiting room
last time you had a coffee yeah yeah so
so again I'm I think that blood pressure
is a very difficult thing to to
accurately glean in the doctor's office
for all those reasons and that's why I
just think everybody should you know buy
one I I don't have any affiliation with
any company that makes these things but
there's a brand that I like called Omron
Omron that's the one we tell our
patients to get you can get these things
on Amazon and
um
what are the most common
uh lifestyle interventions let's say
that someone does get to what that 120
over 80. where should they go first what
do you think exercise is is a big one
aerobic exercise is an enormous way to
lower blood pressure as is weight loss
so weight loss is going to be mostly
driven by nutrition and then aerobic
exercise and and sleep so because I
track my blood pressure pretty regularly
um two of the most obvious things that
show up when I'm not well slept is you
know higher blood glucose and higher
blood pressure what's happening people
if you enjoyed that at then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace